hello and welcome to this video on plane
is to again it's he's close to becoming
my most frequent opponent last game
wasn't great really not he's going for
this a six month which is mighty
irritating whatever prevent Bishop g4
after no they ever tried this before
I'm just a six moon just develop him
it's a really hot positioner it looks a
lot like a French defense but he's got
g6 played that is in kind of it makes
sense it's not like this is pointless
really not my bishop is putting pressure
on on deform Knight h5 Knight f4 is the
move that that concerns me and this
could happen this is not a position I
really feel comfortable with
not don't have so much experience with
1.e4 and sometimes it shows really that
I mean then I get into positions where
it might be okay but I don't know
exactly how how the position is supposed
to be played
okay here I provoked this so that night
age five is not coming all that all that
quickly no night age five I can take on
g5 preparing Bishop c2 23 then maybe 95
it's my idea
time wise I'm a bit behind
I don't think Knight a5 is anything F 95
so okay now let's do this I'm ready now
495
okay prevent it
as long as he cannot move they have six
night I'm going to be going to be okay
for sure I can just double yeah double
on me you phone
I mean I'm I think I'm okay anyway I
just just don't feel very much at home
here
oh yeah this is the move that I
shouldn't have overlooked it's like the
most obvious move ever
yeah I can do that so don't think it's
even all that bad but I didn't didn't go
for this voluntarily
and now my dears Bishop back and then my
g5 push it back and then 95 okay so
finally finally I get there and he
cannot take it due to this fork and I've
got f4 lined up next
if I take taking six is just hanging and
green tea eggs I've got F form you
should pay for no leads nowhere
[Music]
the f4 takes takes 94 this this could be
could be a problem
this is also possible right took me a
long time to see that idea
don't know how good is this but again
it's something that I could have come up
a little bit earlier I totally totally
forgot dad that he can now trade queens
actually that's that's that's annoying
to say the least
[Music]
you know just it's equal equal material
and probably not much going on
yeah probably there was something more
possible but I just didn't see it
but a guy could be checkmated him
probably should not do that
still quite dry of course
anyway to do something yeah I don't
don't think so
if porn
they're just extremely dry
I could have made a draw I mean it's
kind of kind of weird to not make a draw
because I'm definitely not having any
winning chances I'm playing it really
badly
oh come on come on
I should at least pay a little bit of
attention and I completely that was
terrible I didn't want to make a draw
simply and just make a draw there I mean
if you have a position like that you
don't want to make a draw anymore
but okay this does that has nothing to
do with with the end of the game sure
yeah h 1 h 4 was not best was not best
yeah I don't know I was just absolutely
not having drawn my mind I mean even in
this ending I'm better but it didn't it
didn't it was not enough to win any
basically blundered into being a pawn
Darwin which was not necessary but it's
silly wrong I simply did not want to
make it yeah and draw of course with any
any kind of thing of it just here just
this is silly it's just silly because my
pawn is is hey this is this is the worst
move ever yeah
King u6 like it's totally useless
it's like trivial question mark
and just anything King whatever and I
make it still make it wrong but it's
it's totally rotten to get there because
if anybody is better he it must be black
so it's there's no upside
you just cannot win ever so I should
make a draw but you have to simply
forget that it was such a such a
one-sided game up to a point and you
just make a draw there yeah okay yeah
this is this is gifting points away just
like form for no reason or whatever if
you don't want to make draws okay thanks
for watching